Germany's chance Lord of Schultz is just
back from a bridge building trip to
Beijing but the debate over the sale of
critical German infrastructure to China
well it continues the German government
looks set to block the sale of a chip
production facility owned by the
Dortmund based company Elmos to Sweden
Silex which is a unit of China's PSI
Group
the German intelligence service had
warned of security concerns but
initially it looked like the sale would
go ahead especially after Mr Schultz
pushed through the sale of a almost 25
stake in a Hamburg Port Terminal to
Chinese shipping giant Costco now the
company looks to sale looks like it
would be prohibited
DW business reporter Cassandra Sund is
here to give us some more insight
Cassandra tell us more about Elmos this
chip maker and what exactly is at stake
here well you've outlined it pretty good
so far but let me elaborate a little bit
the drama really does start last year at
the end of 2021 it looks like the sale
of this unit in Dortmund in the west of
Germany is going to go ahead uh the
company had announced its intention to
sell the production of the so-called
wafers in Dortmund to Silex for a total
of about 85 million dollars but this
Swedish company was owned by the Chinese
PSI Group at the time Elmo's management
was saying that it was pushing for the
sale because it needed an outside
investor to secure the future of the
site and it was under these conditions
then initially it looked like the
economy Ministry was going to approve
the deal and for once the chancellery
and the economy Ministry seemed like
they were on the same page but now we're
getting news that uh that might not be
the case and tomorrow we could get an
official decision that it's being
reversed the government speaking with
one voice certainly a good thing why
would the government block the steel
when it just greenlit the sale of uh or
when it allowed Costco to buy into a
terminal at the Hamburg Port well it
might actually be because of that deal
there was a ton of pushback as the deal
kind of got revised and moved forward
last week and it might just frankly look
bad for Berlin to look like it's giving
another thumbs up to another deal
involving China to uh involved with what
some might call critical infrastructure
so this might be a situation where
because that deal was so controversial
politically both internationally the US
even weighed in a little bit and
domestically that this deal with Silex
and Elmos might uh get the get the chop
we have to say though that a final
decision has not been made public yet
the German cabinets the cabinet is
likely to decide on Wednesday on that
Cassandra Santa of DW business thank you